you're standing in the mountains of El
Salvador and a 14-year old little girl
walks up and hands you her little baby
boy Jose he's emaciated and he has dirt
and the crinkles of his skin
he's dying of starvation you looked down
into his eyes and he looks back up at
you and you're overcome with love for
him his mother begs you for help she
can't afford the quarter that it cost to
ride the bus into the hospital eight
years ago I held Jose just before he
died today alone 20,000 kids are going
to die of hunger just like Jose the
stats are stats and they don't have the
power to transform us or the world would
be a different place but that day
Jose became my brother and he continues
to live on in my heart and in my
conscience in my relationship with Jose
and the other brothers and sisters I've
met in the developing world in places
like Palestine Haiti Afghanistan they
posed my life with this life-changing
question that I would like to pose to
all of you today are you willing to
choose life over luxury few years later
I'm back home in the United States at a
party it's actually a charity benefit
and businessmen and women are getting
out of their BMWs and Lexus and designer
clothes and ensure these people are
ballers even the babies are rolling up
in thousand-dollar strollers
and everybody's dancing having a good
time and just for a fact let's say
they're dancing to this
fortunately for them their dancing is
much better than mine they actually use
more than their shoulders and have some
rhythm but huh
by almost every measure success these
these men and women have made it you
know they they're living the American
dream
and you know not only are they you know
amassing fortunes they're sharing some
of that by writing checks for the needy
that night I sit down to dinner and
before me sits this nice big juicy steak
unless I cost the host over $100 and I
think to myself for this for the price
of this one meal
Jose could have eaten for an entire year
and I can't eat it because Jose is with
me and he's my brother and I wrestle
with this quote that I read by John
Ruskin and I've wrestled with it a lot
and it says luxury can only be enjoyed
by the ignorant for even a king at his
feast could not enjoy it he must sit
blindfolded because if he recognized the
suffering which accompanies it in the
world he couldn't enjoy it remove the
veil remove the veil so there's a hotel
room down in Haiti that I visited when I
was working with the Haitian ambassador
and it's a nice hotel it's got a
pristine pool mint on the pillow
massages on order and you walk over to
the double doors and you remove the veil
and you're confronted with your view
it's a sea of blue tarps flapping in the
wind
over mud floors overflowing with
families who have lost their homes in
the earthquake it's teeming with trash
urine feces and cholera
now let me ask you this would you be
able to enjoy treating yourself like
luxury and royalty inside this hotel
room when just off your balcony the
masses are dying of unmet
basic needs would you and what makes
this situation so very different from
treating ourselves like royalty with the
luxuries we enjoy every day just a short
plane ride away you know we live in one
of the wealthiest societies the world
has ever known even if you're at the
poverty line here in the United States
around eleven thousand dollars a day
that puts you in the top 20 percent of
the richest people on the planet out
here off the balcony we have a third of
the world's population that lives and
dies on less than $2 a day struggling to
merely survive and the gap between us
and them is getting wider and wider
every single year but stats are stats
and Jose is our brother and he joins in
unison with a third of the world's
population today to pose to us a
challenge are you willing to choose life
over luxury so what does this mean
choosing life over luxury well by way of
example I'd like to tell you about one
man's story who really inspires me
siddhartha gautama was a wealthy prince
who lived over 2,500 years ago in the
foothills of the Himalayan mountains as
the story goes he had every imaginable
luxury he lived a sheltered life in his
castle until one day when he was about
our age he goes out on a carriage ride
and he removes the veil and he sees true
suffering in the world for the first
time he ends up going back to his palace
and all of those luxuries he previously
enjoyed now seemed hollow fleeting
pleasures incapable of bringing true
fulfillment so what does he do he
actually goes out into the world he
leaves it all behind and he deprives
himself of absolutely everything but
this too does not bring fulfillment so
he struggles and eventually he finds
this middle
way between excess and deprivation and
it's on this middle way that he comes to
know enlightenment and he earns the
title of the Buddha enlightenment
fulfillment that's why we're all here
right well notice that the Buddha didn't
get it by going back to his palace and
by writing a check and continuing his
own life of luxury he couldn't do it he
dug deeper than his own pocketbook and
he recognized it's not about how much we
give it's about how fully we give how
completely we give of ourselves the
Buddha chose life over luxury so I know
what everyone in here must be thinking
right now at this point whoa
total buzzkill debbie downer of the
stage well actually I'm not here to make
anybody feel guilty in fact the exact
opposite this has brought this approach
to life it's brought me an unimaginable
amount of joy sacred meaning and purpose
you know rather than seeking out
fulfillment by trying to climb higher
and higher up this wealth and status
ladder then with Jose at my side I've
hopped off the ladder now like a roof
over my head a hot shower a bed a full
stomach these things are seen for the
global luxuries they actually are an
abundant gratitude emerges from
simplicity what I'd like to ask each and
every one of you to do to do is this
travel to the developing world if you
haven't already go to the developing
world and create a meaningful loving
authentic relationship with someone in
extreme poverty in the developing world
remove the veil step out of your comfort
zone and turn these people from
statistics into your brothers and
sisters it's through their friendship
that will come to realize you know
recognize our own love
juries are on consumption choices even
our own goals begin to transform and our
brothers and sisters will help us to
find the middle way and it's out of love
for them we'll choose life over luxury
ultimately
it's not about us saving Jose and those
in the developing world it's about them
saving us